[Music]
how many of you all have ever had a one
hour layover so during this one-hour
layover it's hard to sit down and get a
form of mail it's hard to pull out your
computer to do any work it's hard to
take a nap so what do most people turn
to social media so this is exactly what
Justine did during her layover from
London to South Africa she turned to
social media to entertain her first she
tweeted about a guy in first class who
decided not to wear deodorant
highlighting did he not have enough
money to buy deodorant she got no
responses next she tweeted about the
cucumber sandwich and how cold it was
for her sensitive teeth no responses so
she took the social media one more time
with her 170 followers she tweeted going
to Africa hope I don't get AIDS just
kidding I'm white she had 30 minutes
left of her layover she sporadically
checked in no responses she wasn't too
surprised given the fact that she only
had 175 hours
she wanted her plane for her 11 hour
flight to South Africa and when she
landed things were drastically different
she landed two people tweeting about the
fact that oh this would be bad when she
lands she landed two people tweeting
about oh you're getting fired she landed
two people tweeting even companies about
using this as marketing materials next
time you get on the plane make sure that
you have gogo Wi-Fi so you can check
social media more often justine was a
senior director of corporate
communications so you all may be
thinking this can't happen to you but it
happened to her this is showing over
time how justine was searched on google
overnight her life was changed
and she was fired from her dream job so
today we're gonna talk to you about how
one post can impact your life how one
Pope's can ruin your life how one post
can make your life and Breyers chris is
going to talk about how one post could
impact your life so what do they
actually mean by one post can impact
your life and why should you care go
into the workplace we're going to go
through a few stats from a career
builder survey with over 2,000 current
active hiring managers in the u.s. so to
kick us off more than half of hiring
managers have found social media red
flags as a reason to not extend you a
job offer
so are you focusing on your resume the
cover letter
maybe that illusive personal
recommendation maybe your social media
is hiding in the background and putting
you in some hot water let's say you make
it through that gauntlet you've dodged
all the bullets you've got the job
congratulations who's safe right now
again more than half of firms are using
social media to research current
employees but what does that actually
mean but social media can take many
forms it's a pretty loose term you may
be thinking of your Instagram your
Facebook of course but think more that
medium blog post would you liked that
comment you made on a podcast or your
LinkedIn profile social media can take
many forms and they can all affect you
but again maybe you're thinking so what
my job's 9 to 5 it doesn't matter what
I'm doing at the weekend what I'm
posting surely it's a free country
well true but more than a third of
employers have disciplined or fired
someone because of current social media
activity and these are not big celebrity
showcase moments these are everyday
people doing everyday things that you
may be shocked that have got them in
trouble and chin will walk you through
some examples so you may be thinking now
honestly Chris I didn't even like social
media should I just delete everything
it's a nice idea but unfortunately the
worst number of all is 57% of the firms
actually find it worse if you're a
visitor
I know so what should I do
well honestly before we get into the
solutions right now just think these are
not small numbers clearly your current
employers potential employers are very
well versed in social media and they
certainly use it to evaluate you in the
hiring process in your quarterly reviews
and you could even be fired for it so
right now chin is going to walk us
through some examples of how one post
contrôlée Bruin now you may be wondering
okay so I have to maintain the social
media presence so that I'm not invisible
but this is just so risky I'm what are
the some of the reflex that I should
avoid I don't want to end up as one of
the 34% who got fired or who got
disciplined because of some social media
reflex what are the things that I should
look out for so here I'm gonna give you
two real-life examples they were
completely set you're thinking
sure is an example of a picture posted
by a social media user that got her
fired can anyone guess why
right okay so that's actually no
breaking of the law
there's nothing clearly out of place
except for this little detail over here
so the social media user had been to a
cocktail party celebrating the closure
of a major deal with a new client the
cocktail party was being held at the
premises of the new client and that's
it's no goalie can see out there and
then she posted a picture on social
media but she posted it before the deal
was meant to be announced in so doing
she breached confidentiality causes and
she was fired as a result the victim
Kuwait here is that you've got to be
hyper wealth everything that you're
posting check and recheck your post
especially pictures make sure that
everything in the foreground and the
background are all appropriate before
you hit that post button next example
this is sheriff BJ Roberts from Hampton
Virginia
in 2009 he fired a man named Bobby
Blaine and four of his co-workers from
the Sheriff's Department why because in
2009 but he was standing for re-election
the five of them went to like the
Facebook page of this major mr. Jim
Davis who was his main rival during the
election campaign so turns out mr.
Roberts won the election and promptly
fired five of them citing budgetary
constraints the satisfactory work
performance and a general lack of
harmony and efficiency in the Sheriff's
Department
so while we may not agree with what mr.
Roberts has done the bigger takeaway
here is that you make statements with
your likes in the social media space any
activity that you perform can it will be
construed as your personal statements of
position and taken of that your career
so if your company or your prospective
company are cautious they are likely to
have drawn up detailed social media
guidelines to tell you to tell employees
what they should or should not do
Media so be sure to look up those
guidelines whether your company has them
and above all remember that you make
statements of your likes but it is not
all gloom and doom I will now hand over
to Haley who talked about how one post
can also make your career so I will also
share two examples of how a post can
make your career how many people know
who this is yet not many people know
that he was discovered on social media
in 2007 Justin Bieber took and sharing
one of his covers to another artist on
YouTube his manager was scrolling for
YouTube looking at different videos and
came across this video he was so
impressed with Justin's voice he spent
the rest of the day going through the
rest of the content that Justin had
shared on YouTube and fell in love
he quickly set up a meeting between
Justin Bieber and Usher and the rest was
history this is the highlight the fact
that sharing your interests and your
passions of social media can help make a
career that you're not even trying to
have yet you never know who your
audience is and who was out there
looking for a new opportunity for you
however if you're thinking I don't have
any artistic talents or something that I
can showcase on social media there's
other ways to also make your career
Suzanne had follow a VP of a large
company multiple years ago she started
liking some of the posts that he made
responding to his interactions really
interesting and liked his company and
the strategies that he was putting in
place this one sweet sent her off on a
completely new trajectory he had just
mentioned the fact that he had started
yam ink yammering on a social media
platform however while everyone else was
praising the fact of him taking this new
step she made an interesting comment of
she's tried this before and not everyone
has he was interested he was interested
in how honest she was
it's not going to look more into her
background she looked he looked through
her social media tweets and saw that she
was really good at bringing community
together he offered her a job as
director of community engagement and the
rest was history this highlight said
even if it's not content that you're
creating but just responding to other
people's content that you're passionate
about can highlight opportunities to get
involved in a career that you otherwise
would not have dreamed of so now Chris
is gonna highlight some of the takeaways
so as Haley and Qin pass out our handout
in which you'll see five key takeaways
as long as a social media checklist
which will encourage you to use this
Thanksgiving to scrub so make sure
everything online is relevant how you
want to be seen but the key takeaways
one have a social media presence as
we've discussed being invisible is not a
solution here to be hyper aware of
everything you post even the smallest
background detail can really make or
break number three you really make
statements with your life it's light
it's important to be intentional about
everything you like and share online
number four post content that really
showcases your talents you'd be
surprised how far this can take you and
number five
simply strike up conversations about
your interests you really have no idea
where they could lead so remember one
post can impact your career one post
could make your career from one post can
ruin your heart we're now open for
questions
[Music]